hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the night that speaks now
this is a very stylized pixelated horror
game as you can see right here and when
I saw previews for this one it reminded
me very much of this game that I played
a long time ago called hide which I had
to revisit just before I started this
one and the reason it reminds me of that
oh hi Oh what are you is because the
extreme low res uh of this game reminded
me of like early gameboy games and this
is a horror game
hi
Zek oh oh alright this is this is the
power that I was looking for because I
saw screenshot of this hand being able
to do the middle finger defense which is
the ultimate defense against all demons
oh jeez
oh gosh okay so oh oh I've got
okay it's time for the gong man where am
I
whoa easy to pick up she was perfect in
every way she was intelligent beautiful
and loved by everyone she wanted to live
forever okay it is said that a strong
sense of will can solve any problem in
front of you holds II to exert your will
ah that's my will [ __ ] you better back
off any monstrosity that are in this
game or what is this oh the doors open
the other way all right
um I'm exerting my will as hard as I can
channeling it through a single finger
all right anyway so that's hilarious Lu
whoa is that a face or is that something
else
ow my neck I didn't think that was
actually a face I thought I was crying
I'm not crying they exert my will again
god damn it what was that obviously it
was a face we've determined that it was
a face someone in here is crying
weird okay ah yes she always knew what
to do she didn't need to listen to
anyone but this darkness it speaks you
must listen
yeah I've been listening I've been
listening to the moaning in the crying
sounds like a bunch of bubble-blowing
babies who is that a thing ah better not
be a bird huh oh it was a thing okay so
it was a thing but it was a dead thing
so I don't need to worry about it she
was brave and determined the knight
called her forth and she came willingly
then she now what about this guy
probably not this guy
you didn't come willingly everybody
everybody out there oh whoa
okay another Skellington why big jar why
oh I'll take my will Oh take my strong
will what was that supposed to be hello
hi did you not like my incredible will
huh oh I can't see a thing
oh boy
oh is it coming oh it's it coming huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah take that will oh oh
whoa my will ain't strong enough forever
I guess
huh ah let me go down this way please
oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez hello oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god open
oh geez this ain't good ah she knew
there was a way out she'll is learned
listen for the change and for the
grounds of that leg oh [ __ ] I didn't
learn to live through the chains of the
deep all right let's try that again
I thought for some reason in my mind I
thought that it paused the game when I
was shut up I'm trying to do a thing I
thought that it paused the game when I
was reading a note I don't know why I
thought that but that's what I thought
okay so where is it dropping
okay so I'm back here with a note about
the chains so I just got to keep an ear
out huh
that sounds pretty unpleasant let me go
towards that sound oh good oh great
oh yeah yeah yeah you know no I'm coming
for you
I'll help ah dirty my will yes what I
thought okay up okay maybe I need to go
down that way I don't know oh oh okay I
uh I can't sidestep I can't yeah I can't
I can only turn so I can't strafe around
him while still looking at him I gotta
be I gotta be exerting all my finger
power directly into his face alright
this time I intend to rush a little less
headlong into death because that seems
to be the primary thing that's [ __ ]
up my steez tables
do you have ki-woo computer that [ __ ]
you computer what did you ever do for
humanity fry oh honey a good son
she is dead but she doesn't know it I
thought you wanted to live forever was I
are you whoa I saw something there
well where'd it go there was something
there proceed to pick up I did that what
was that I saw like teeth who where is
it where is it oh it's coming by me
isn't it yeah
I don't know where I'm going I'm
probably going in a freaking circle God
David I am on whoa what is that hello oh
she was perfect in every way she was it
wide she would live forever I is that
different than no one but I think that's
different because the other one said she
wanted to live forever and that one said
she would hey hey there's okay Hey hello
ladies any of that worked hard there was
always a solution this case was no
different oh good yeah okay now I have
gone in a circle that skeleton is like a
landmark for it's behind me but that
thing is definitely following me oh [ __ ]
Oh shitty tits Oh shitty tits get out
here get out here you know I don't know
what you are where you are where you're
doing what you're doing
that guy better get out of here we're
not step Oh
it's definitively after me huh oh god
where am I now I've entered a dungeon Oh
two dead end oh oh oh whoa [ __ ] yeah
they did it did I focus my will
there was only static on the television
the computers were worse there was
something she couldn't see over there
yeah no joke oh [ __ ] oh I'm [ __ ]
oh I'm [ __ ]
one [ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's it dude boy I'm
focusing my lap whoa hey I can't tell
the [ __ ] a get away I can't get around
him and look at him is he gone oh he's
gone huh whoa [ __ ] off dude okay so I
can make them go away if I blast them
with the middle finger as hard as I can
uh whoa whoa whoa hey whoa hey whoa yeah
that's right you better get out of here
okay so that's good cuz that means
eventually I'll be able to get a defense
against these guys if they corner okay
there's the door hi and bye okay so
that's the door so that means that
somewhere in the middle section of all
this stuff there's a key at least that
would be my my guess man these things
are crawling
ha ha nnnn nnnn nnnn nnnn nnnn Oh our
new new new all right um okay there must
be a point to the notes like there has
to be a point to the notes either
it pieces together I mean obviously the
notes are telling a story but otherwise
I'm just wandering lost so he's got to
be a reason
between the okay hang on that dam has
stopped that between the lanterns there
yeah go away please
between the lanterns there was a cold
wind she fell through there was
something she couldn't see okay does
that mean like who Hey that guy was
quiet I was a stealthy dude why is there
something in front of my face oh never
mind just two lanterns here oh oh well I
would have thought that I would have
walked over here anyway god dammit that
was a big waste of time
okay whoa what am i doing
how about you whoa it's Hogwarts with
the candles okay okay how convenient
Ernie then what does that say you we
will no pain
oh you will no pain oh I already no pain
thank you very much I know the pain of
not knowing where the hell I'm going are
they gonna be able to go through there
well this hardly seems fair
how am I supposed to be able to get him
out from no no shiitake
I can't middle finger blast them through
the wall oh maybe I can hope I did okay
nevermind I didn't know my
finger-blasting powers were nevermind
god damn it
okay we're gonna carry on cuz we got the
key and then we're gonna go over there
and then we're gonna be able to open the
door finally progress which would be
nice hello oh [ __ ] oh damn it is it the
sound of someone laughing at me you know
I don't like that
oh it's coughing you heard the stories
you didn't care you will live forever
welcome to the darkness oh oh I can't
move oh [ __ ] ah middle fears activate is
that my boy
ow oh oh I get it
oh I get it oh I get it
oh that's the end holy [ __ ] she wanted
to live forever so she became a monster
a never-ending always wandering the
halls monster and then I chased after
her looking for eternal youth and I
became a monster myself so that's
interesting a short little horror game
with an interesting like hard to
determine story is that oh is that like
a turkey on the wall there a bird or
something I don't know what that is
looked gross so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to check
out old school pixelated horror games
that I played in the past you can check
the link in the description or click the
annotation so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
no no no good night good night
ah thank God I got my hey I got me run
me back